I'm going to go through this algebra--so if you are an ace in solving this sort of systems of equation
you can skip this part, but for those who aren't, I'm going to walk you through it.
So, here we have our two equations.
I'd like to write them one above the other to make thing a little simpler for me.
Now my goal is to eventually know what the acceleration of the system is.
I'm going to do that by, first, solving for the tension in one of these equations and then plugging in
and let me show you what I mean by that, so let's take this equation.
If I move this term to this side, I find that the tension is equal m₁a
and a is still unknown plus m₁g.
I'm going to plug this in, this value of the tension, in to here.
The idea of being that, now I'll get this equation in terms of only one unknown, a,
and FT won't show up anymore.
So rewrite m₂g minus FT, but now I'm using this, now equals m₂a.
Let's just distribute this minus sign and remove the parenthesis.
Well now I'm solving for a, so let's group all the a terms together.
I'm going to move this a over here, okay?
So, now that we've done that, I'm going to take out the common factors
of each of these terms and each of these terms.
For example, each of these terms has g in it and each of these terms has an a in it,
and now we're really close.
Let's divide both sides by this term here,
and here is our answer and this is truly a thing of beauty and let me explain why.